hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zurück weil die
tritte biest wir haben ja gerade den
typen da besiegten zurückgegangen und
dann passierte hier noch ein paar
komische dinge und zwar weniger
reingelaufen betten ja dieses dieses
portal und da oben einzeln dann bin ich
auch gestorben
wenn ihr gesehen wollt wie das aus
meiner perspektive war dann geht auf
meine zweite kanal des videos auch und
in der beschreibung verlinkt davis
hochgeladen und bei simon das ist
einfach hinter seiner letzten folge
geschnittener könnte es noch auf simons
perspektive sehen und das war nicht so
schön also ihr seht hier latest es war
genau hier
ich habe mich aber ich hab mich
kaputtgelacht lacht und ja weil wir
beide hier gestorben sind und jetzt habe
ich gleich voraussetzungen
wir gehen deshalb änderungen oder immer
nur wissen wir schlafen conny aber
irgendwann meint hierbei ein monster ich
habe keine lust werft diese monster nett
aber wir hatten einfach den monstern
einen buchsbaum herkömmliche monster
fall bahn ist die automatische falls sie
machen
wir könnten drumrum einfach alles
ausleuchten alternative so wie ich
komplett du kannst wenn du kleine leute
die sache ist auch die wir nehmen
diesmal nur zwei folgen dieser aufnahme
session auf als plätze und diese damit
ihr uns wieder fleißig kommentare
schreiben könnt also wenn irgendwelche
tipps tricks themen täter habe dann
einfach und in die kommentare schreiben
und das sind die goldenen 3ds merkt sich
das tipps tricks und themen tipps tricks
und truck also schreibt das patentieren
schreibt einfach in die kommentare ein
paar tipps und so was machen mit dieser
folge ich möchte diamanten suche ich
habe ich nicht in einer folge wir
wollten doch das dings bauen und stratec
ja mal einfach drückt und dann die einer
saisonal gast geld wollten damit kann
man sich schon kann man sich damit nicht
bauen wie ein schwert das kellerfenster
lagerschuppen türkisch portugiesisch
afrika simon wie sieht das aus
wer diese für ein fenster gereicht es
hat nur für ein fahrzeug gereicht aber
er bringt nix hat fire protection 1 oder
so ich kann hier auf den iran geben
die branche stellt die bringt mehr im
katalog den job ja da hast du zweite
kommen hier das gibt dir auch oder
willst ich hab den fast zurück ich habe
dir getötet ich hab die ganze
draufgeschlagen
und so dass ihr diese rolle was die
alten fehler ich hab sofort auch nochmal
wiederkommen ich geb dir mal die bürger
das war ein großer großer fehler nein
was auch klappt warte ich glaube im
wasser kann man nicht fortsetzen oder
das weiß man nicht
ich mache besser geworden
das ist wie
auf dem alter der nagas geld ist doch
kein bisschen besser du lusche aha du
opfer
wir können dieser form ein thema
sprechen wir nicht so viel zeit haben um
auch was wirklich profis tun
ich würde das thema block besser
ansprechen lausanne sport und dem
release von spawn sport ist draußen
bleibe ich gerne bis habt ihr spongebobs
gesehen wenn ich kurz nach ich habe die
besteigung von links spongebobs was
haltet ihr davon ab welche eure konnten
zulegen konnte was hältst du von
spongebob hier ist klar ich muss ja
irgendwie vorsieht mann weglaufen online
er weder trotzdem einen namen fakt dass
ist so mit nieten jetzt so mein gott
warte mal ganz kurz mit den portalen
alter komplett ist immer bitter an
bist du da sehr gut sind dass diamanten
was wo ich hatte mir das wert ist
richtig geladen
bestätigen wollte ich glaube das was was
meinst du diamant guck dir das mal an da
und warte sind dass ihr diamanten warten
hatte
jetzt machen wir kein portal ich hab dir
schon gezeigt ich mach keine
mach mal bitte kein portal jaja so drauf
setzen wir wissen faible kristian
westerveld tanz und das ist der knaller
so drauf
ich will diese portugal zurück alter ich
habe mich heute gefühlt wegfall weg von
mir ich will ihnen die noch sein boss
töten
du hast einfach sein portal in gesetztem
lutscher ich bin recht ich bin fast tot
alter ja und was passiert dann deutlich
verfolge das passiert dann
natürlich diesem einfluss musik so laut
mitteilung
ich habe musik gott ich sehe schon
kommen weil ich bin total aber steuer
welche jetzt einfach mal wieder in den
einstellungen gefuchtelt habe nur damit
du mich vernünftig ist
ja aber wenn wir jetzt einfach die leute
sagen hey ist an beide unter die
qualität schlechter haben dass er
nächste folge ausgebessert deswegen
machen das ja damit wir auch eure kriegt
kritik umsetzen können eure krieg kritik
kon ii.de heißt dass zwischen der bruder
von gaga er wurde in wo bist du denn ich
werde mir auf der karte du bist so weit
weg
ich bin also ich habe schon riesig
hätten die saison riesigen berg gerade
wo bist du denn da ist mir der schlucht
wieder aber ich bin fast tot ist das ist
doch mal bitte ich geb dir auch den naga
scale
na ja ist schon ok labs inhalten alter
wenn du mir wenn du mich jetzt tötet man
das richtig ran sich selbst für sich
nichts für dich nicht ich möchte ja du
hast dich doch du hast wochenschluss
unter schubsen malta ich hab dir
waldläufer lassen
ich geb dir den lagers gehen private
kann man hier wartet die teile sind cool
hast du erst mal was zu essen für mich
war ja am sande schaffen
danke
zum glück hat honda licht spenden aus
hast du diesen überblick gefordert ich
bin tot ich bin tot ich bin fast tot
das kann neben zerstören
ich habe ein halbes jahr zurück an den
ort zurück in unsere welt ausgemacht
stets wird unsere welt ich bin zu rücken
unserer welt will zurück in unserer welt
doch diese folge eine welt möchte sie
gerne dieser welt auch noch erkunden
ihr könnt also auf die nächste folge auf
jeden fall auch freuen in dieser neuen
welt die welt erkunden
ja die letzten folgen dieses bzw dieser
erfolg ist relativ
sagen wir chaotisch ganz einfach nicht
frontal in der mittagssonne und ja
wir haben geschlafen minute konnte
aufgestanden doch jetzt kehrt für ihn
aber nicht aufs feld kommen also heißt
40 minuten ja eigentlich 40 00 so was
ich nehme jetzt immer so ein paar ärzte
die wir hier drin haben weil er meint
ihr ein paar leute die einfach daran
dass links rein tun sollen
in diese mails raider teil dafür
bräuchte erstmal so hatten wir dennoch
mal kohle haben wir kohle halte aber wir
haben aber auf jeden fall ne menge aber
er macht du mal bitte das ganze drama
was wir haben
kopper cable okay die macht es noch mal
ganz genau wann investiert gucken kohle
da kann ich ja nicht den kopf
cable körper cable koffer koffer koffer
koffer körper erwartet so geht das
electric fördert jetzt mache ich
aluminium zu ok alle die sauna und werte
sind komplett weg dies auch sonst viel
zu leise ich hoffe nicht wenn mussawi
alles bewegliche gleichstellen also habe
ich den körper hier
was meint ihr welche wenn wir im mai
trader oder irgendwie etwas mehr rein
tun oder sondern kriegen wir da auch
mehr ärzte raus aber ich versteh ich das
gerade nicht so ganz
also wenn ihr da wirklich weiter wisst
dann schreibt sie doch einfach in die
kommentare
und dann würde ich sagen wir in der
nächsten folge wieder oder was ist das
sagen wollte ist oder in folge jetzt
mache ich würde sagen mit dem wir nehmen
das über so damit wir jetzt auch
wirklich auf die leute eingehen können
weil wir noch ganz wichtig dass wir auch
die die wünsche der zuschauer setzten
und das ist ja auch wichtig genau das
heißt wenn es euch gefallen hat auf
jeden fall erstmal daumen hoch geben und
dann wenn irgendwelche tipps tricks
themen habt einfach und in die
kommentare schreiben am liebsten leben
nie wirklich zur zeit einfach tipps und
tricks irgendwie wir hier noch sachen
verbessern können wir zum beispiel
jetpack besser macht
können und so was alles und und wie das
wichtig ist wer sowas schnell machen
können also wie wir schnell vorankommen
also sozusagen so was wie haut zu next
step die ist das also sagte ich mal
einfach am besten so soll es einen
kleinen plan den wir umsetzen können um
schnell voranzukommen
genau das hat er eine person schon mal
gemacht und ja dann will ich sagen mit
dem blick auf simon sage ich tschüss bis
zum nächsten mal bisher nicht